Hello Freak bitches.
These are called sea org members are
not talking about average Scientologists
and explain,
explain to me to see,
because was that established when
l Ron Hubbard was evading taxes?
[inaudible] ship?
Yes.
And He created this ship called the free
winds and whatever that ship called the
free winds.
It is called the free ones now,
but that's where they deliver the highest
level of of Scientology, their Ota.
So when you get to Ota, you got to
get on the phones. But before that,
I don't know the name of his boats,
but I think it was called the Apollo.
That was a part of going clear. That
was hilarious. When, um, who was it?
One of the writers are one of
the, the Haggis. Yes. When he,
we received like the highest level shit.
That wasn't even the highest level.
It wasn't even, that was OT three.
Really? Yeah. And uh, and when I read it,
I literally, you know, you
have to go into a secure room.
We just want to talk us through
that. What is that? First of all,
you have to get invited.
You have to get an invitation.
So you'd been Scientology for years.
You'd spend a ton of money around
of my most cited, by the way,
most Scientologists don't even get to
this most. Most don't. Right? Yeah.
Cause you have to be wealthy to get to
this knowing you have to be wealthy.
But a lot of times what they do
that the new scam is you got to go,
you get to a level and then they go,
oh we messed that up.
You have to go back down at your expense.
Right. You have to Redo that part.
You were talking about that
on your show. Yeah. Yeah.
So then there will rewrite some new
thing and now David Miscavige rewrites
things and says he found it in a vault
somewhere and we all believe it baby.
Honestly, we all believe it cause we want
to believe it. So it talk me through,
so you go through this rigor level. Did
you get to OT five? Oo, yeah. Close.
Yeah. Yeah. Cause um, I uh,
I got it to a sauna when, so you to
get to this advanced level, this is,
it's called advanced levels. Right?
Right. Uh, you are put through the ringer.
They go through every folder.
You know,
from the moment you walk into a church
of Scientology, they have folders on you.
Everything you've ever said is written
down and an and videotaped. Okay. So they,
they um, they get your folders and
they, they call it, they call it,
they go through it.
Okay.
And they go through every transgression
or you still humping your pillow.
Are you still, uh, you know, a nasty
ass home to your mother? Like they,
they go through everything.
Are you still connected to this person
who says something bad about Scientology
20 years ago?
So they make sure that you're
eligible to get the advanced data?
And where do they bring you?
Your Room? Where's it at? It's a,
it's on l Ron Hubbard way in Los
Angeles and fountain. It's cool. Hey,
how nervous are you? Are you freaking
out? Oh my God, I can't wait.
This happened only all the Shit
I've put up with all my life.
It's finally going to be answered.
All my questions of life.
We're going to be answered in this moment.
And you realize this is the moment
you're going to get the sacred documents.
So my mother, yeah, so
because I'm a celebrity,
they let my mother come in and she
was also higher level than me. Right.
So imagine I'm in this like double like,
so you go through one door
and the security and then
you got to get to land new.
Did you like it? You got to get like
clearance. You got to go take a picture.
You've got to sign documents and
say, if I ever reveal this, uh,
it's going to be $100,000.
You know,
you don't ever get to read any legal
document that Scientology gives you.
So you just sign things. You know, you
just, they say sign here, sign here.
It's like today what you did here.
So I don't know.
I could be married to you was for
all I know when I signed today. Um,
I like how you shook your
head. No, you don't need to
shy. Okay. So you know comedy,
you don't deny Joe.
So I don't know why he keeps denying it.
That's how you step up coming
another notch. Got It. You deny,
oh wait, oh, I didn't get the
memo. Ah, okay. So there's
what we're doing now. Okay,
got it. Um, so okay,
so you went to her room,
the secure room,
they take your photo while
they give you a folder,
you have to get a briefcase that
only, you know, the uh, co two.
So you go up to the window, to the Aao
window and you hand them your briefcase.
They scan your briefcase and they put
the materials in the briefcase and they
close it.
They turn it back to you and you lock it.
Then you attach the briefcase to your
body. I'm not fucking with him. No.
Like with a little clip like it has
to be physically connected to, right.
So when you go pay, you
have, correct. Okay.
So you get a briefcase,
they go, go to the,
go down the hall and use your thing,
and you're going to get led into one door,
and then you're going to go into another
door and then you're gonna go into the
course room as it was called. So you
go into the three doors or two doors,
whatever it was,
and sit down.
You open up your briefcase and you
read the material for the first time,
the answers. So my mother sitting there
in front of me, okay, she's so excited.
Understand that like, this is what you
want for your kids. Like you're like,
they're getting up the bridge and
they're getting the answers to life.
So when they come back next lifetime,
they're not going to forget everything
and they're not going to be as fucked up
as they were when they were,
you know what I mean? Like it's,
it's really a proud moment,
you know?
And so my mom's sitting across from me
like so excited and I'm reading this,
that my body is made up of other beings,
my body,
my whole body,
my thoughts and everything are mixed in
with these other beings that are make up,
compose my body. Okay. Are
you following me with this?
What's your understanding of it?
Your body's made up of other beings.
Every, every everything.
My thumb is kind of pose,
maybe not the nails, cause they're
acrylic. Your, your skin's other banks,
everything. Everything like
thousands, just here. Just
my thumb is as a person is, uh,
is being trapped into this body.
Okay. So I read this and the
supervisor comes over and he goes,
do you understand? I want you to draw
it out. I want you to draw it out.
So the supervisor has access
to this information. Yeah.
He's standing there to make sure. Right?
So I go like this Gel, I don't know.
I don't know a person. Okay. I go to,
there's a bunch of beings on me like that
and I give it to him like that and he
goes, start again. I want
you to read it again.
And then I want you to draw another
one. It's like, okay. So I did all this,
you know, and I literally did those, Joe,
I mean circles on every part of my body.
He's drawing a stick figure and she's
drawing little circles all over the stick
figure right now.
These beings were like from
75 trillion meat years ago,
they were put in volcanoes and
blown up and packaged and uh,
overlord and a low anyway.
Are you freaking out at this point?
I go, I look at my mother who said,
now the supervisor is standing over me,
so I go,
what in the fuck?
She's like,
no,
there's Ota. Your Mom's Ota. Yeah,
your mom's top of the food chain.
Not only is my mother is probably top
of the food chain when it comes to the
counseling side.
My mother was top of the food chain
when it came to administering cytology,
which is very rare. She was what's
considered a height trained auditor,
but she hadn't read this stuff.
You of course, she read it.
She was just there to see my excitement.
She was just there as a spectator
to see her daughter received.
The answers were super skeptical.
Supervisor comes over and he goes,
what don't you understand? I go,
I understand it. I just, I don't, I don't
love that. Like I'm not happy. I go,
I just got to tell you I'm not happy with
this is what it was. And he goes, well,
you don't need to believe it.
You just need to do it.
So that's the answer that's given to you.
You don't need to believe it.
You just need to do it.
So then you have to go and audit this.
You have to go and do it on yourself.
Talk to these beans on the
meter by yourself. So, uh,
on the meter meeting you hold the cans.
And when I say cans folks,
what they look like? It looks like
soup cans. Like it'd be drained.
All the soup from a soup can and
it had a string attached to it.
It's connect to some. Yeah, you could just
Google what? Scientology he meter. Okay,
so you, so you have to hold the meter
and discussed this? No, you think it,
so now you got to go get your material.
So after you've been checked out on this
and they get that, you get what it is,
then you go back to the window
and they give you your actual,
what you're supposed to do with
this information. So it'll say like,
it'll be a piece of paper and I'll say,
ask this question and then look at
the meter and what the answer is.
Whatever answer comes to your mind, write
it down. Huh? Do you see what I'm saying?
So all you're doing is awakening
these things to talk to them. Really.
Yeah. Right. And so let them go. You're
basically saying like, go be free. Go.
This is OT three. Correct. And by the way,
when I was a scientologist and I heard
that this was a story I didn't know,
so I would go to the Internet
and go OT three story.
But I didn't know if it was
true so I couldn't verify it.
Do you see what I'm saying?
So most people who go,
that's bullshit because they haven't,
they don't know what they're
looking at on the Internet. Right.
There's no one to verify it with.
So if I want some of my mother,
let's say before I got to
this level, they, you're,
you're told to lie to people.
You can't help people what the answers
are because they're going to get
pneumonia, they get pneumonia,
then surely will die. Okay.
So a lot of times when I lied to the price
and then they confronted me on it and
said, why did you lie? I was like, I had
to to save your life. I mean, I can't,
I want to give you cancer.
So if you were about to go to OT
three and then you went online and you
investigated what is OT three and then
you read a bunch of stuff about these
little beings and you bought
it and then asked your mom,
your mom would have to lie to you. She
would lie to me as she did, as she did.
So after you got through this, yeah.
What made you do four and fives?
There's always the carrot of like,
just wait it just by the way,
here's what they do. They set up that
you're the auditor now, so you're,
you're auditing these things in your
body. You're now the boss. So they go,
they tell you, get your hat
on, like your, it's your job.
You don't need to believe anything.
You just need to audit them.
So you need to do your job as an auditor.
That's what they're called.
Auditor's people who are the ones who
take you into session in Scientology,
right? So you feel like
you're in a leadership role.
So you're doing these things a favor,
you know, and you're like, well,
maybe it's true. I don't know. I mean,
I do sometimes hear voices and you know,
like, you know, you have a moment
with yourself and you're like,
I might be really kind of
crazy. Um, so you're like,
maybe this is an answer. It's,
it's sick because it speaks to a side
of you that wants answers about life,
you know? And then you're like,
no, this is some crazy shit man,
that there wasn't even people that know,
you know it. Listen, you believe
what you want to believe at the time.
Does it feel to you at the moment
like maybe if you just keep going,
it get better.
And I'm confused now,
but if I contemplate
this and I write over,
eventually I'm going to receive enough
information. This is all going to be like,
oh right. I was a fool.
Right. So for example,
one time I had talked to a friend about
it, I said, you know, I heard some of us,
some Xenu Shit.
She
pulled me into celebrity center so fast
into a secured room and she handed me my
ass. She said, don't you ever say
that word outside of secured room?
I'm writing in knowledge report
on you. She said, I'm writing
you never say that word out loud
in a room that's not secured.
Okay. And never seen again.
So she wrote a report on the,
she wrote a knowledge report on me.
I got sent to what's called ethics,
which is like the Justice Department
of celebrities of Scientology.
And they said they brought me into another
secured room because they have to get
somebody who knows this information.
And they said, never ever say that.
W say this. It never
confirm it. Never deny it.
Never give that information out, ever.
That just never discuss it. Just say,
I'd never heard of it. You sound
crazy. Wow. And that's what we all say.
You sound crazy or you know,
properly done. You get it. You know,
like you'll get it if it's properly done.
Those people didn't do it properly.
That's why they didn't understand it.
Do you see what I'm saying?